Who would have thought that water in a can
would become the second-best-selling drink
on Amazon?
And not only there.
Liquid Death is believed to be the fastest-growing
non-alcoholic beverage of all time.
It sold its first can in 2019 and raked in
$3 million in revenue that year.
In 2022, the company’s revenue soared to
$130 million.
And is currently valued at $700 million.
CEO Mike Cessario recognized that many people
were looking for a more environmentally-friendly
alternative to plastic water bottles.
What is Liquid Death, are these kids drinkin’?
By packaging water in a can of what looks
like craft beer, Liquid Death created a unique
identity.
But it wasn't just the packaging that made
Liquid Death cool.
It’s the wicked marketing.
For years a bunch of marketing f*?^ boys have
tricked you into thinking water is some girly
drinks for Yoga moms.
Well, hold onto your high heels.
Because I’ve got news.
Water isn’t cute.
Water is deadly.
Their ads are funny and satirical, drawing
people to the brand’s edgy personality.
Water is liquid death.
One of the top comments on this video is:
“I don't mind commercials when they are
as entertaining as this”
Mike told the non-profit news organization
Marketplace: “If you can make people laugh,
they will have a deeper connection with your
brand, regardless of the functional differences
of your liquid.”
Big companies think they set themselves apart
because of unique ingredients.
But those can be replicated easily.
Strong brands mean more to people than the
product itself.
So the CEO of Liquid Death is admitting it’s
not even about the taste of the drink!
Not the worst water I’ve ever tasted.
Mike thinks of his beverage startup as being
like Saturday Night Live, with comedians writing
the skits.
For years, he worked on marketing campaigns,
including for the dairy brand Organic Valley,
which produced this hilarious commercial about
their protein shake.
Just tell a bro it has a tonne of protein,
and he’ll pound the s*&^ out of it.
That sense of humor is written all over the
cans.
The blurb on the side reads: “When a group
of teenagers set off into the mountains for
a weekend of drinking regular water in plastic
bottles, they became hunted by an aluminum
can of mountain water that was dead set on
murdering their thirsts and recycling their
souls,”
The can draws inspiration from the kind of
artwork on popular energy drinks.
Mike got the idea for Liquid Death while attending
the Vans Warped Tour which was sponsored by
the energy drink Monster.
He noticed that band members didn’t want
to consume energy drinks for health reasons.
So, Monster gave them cans filled with water
so they could still promote the brand.
These cans of Monster tour water were not
for sale to the public.
Mike thought to himself: Why not sell water
in a can and market it in the same fun and
rebellious way as energy drinks or beer?
And, it just so happens that alcohol consumption
appears to be on the decline for young people.
Among American adults, Gallup showed that
those aged 18 to 34 are less likely to drink
alcohol than those aged 35 to 54.
A large UK study in 2019 showed 26% of young
people in England are not drinking at all.
Liquid Death says a quarter of its consumers
are Gen Zers, between 18 to 25 years old.
Its TikTok account is the second most followed
of any beverage brand that I could find, after
Red Bull.
Even though some investors thought it was
a dumb idea, Mike knew he was onto something.
The company created buzz on social media even
before launching the product just to see its
potential.
Without even having a real product, we had
more social followers than Aquafina.
Look how many people are messaging us asking
how they can get this.
Look how many people are sharing an image
of a beverage product.
Like, who shares an image of a beverage and
how often on social media?
Not too often.
Their fans are so loyal that they’re getting
the brand permanently etched on their skin.
The company says they know of at least 300
people with Liquid Death tattoos.
Liquid Death has also built brand loyalty
through unusual celebrity endorsements.
Like releasing a limited edition line of Tony
Hawk skateboards infused with his blood.
And they’re gonna use it for skateboard
graphics?
The idea was so provocative that several news
outlets covered it.
Resulting in free publicity.
Liquid Death has expanded its lineup from
selling mountain water and sparkling to include
flavored water and ice teas with witty names
that are a play on phrases:
Convicted Melon - Convicted Felon
Grim Leafer - Grim Reaper
Rest in Peach - Rest in Peace
Liquid Death is a masterclass in the art of
marketing.
It has struck the right balance by being provocative
enough to stand out while not crossing the
line into offensiveness.
Liquid Death’s goal is to become a multi-billion-dollar
beverage company like Red Bull.
I recently used the Blinkist app to absorb
the key concepts on how to build a great company
from the bestselling book Good to Great.
It took only 17 minutes to soak up all the
lessons.
Blinkist taught me that great companies are
focused on what they’re uniquely good at.
The Hedgehog Concept
is based on the idea that hedgehogs do one
thing well - curl up into a protective ball.
Blinkist allows you to understand the key
ideas and concepts for 5,500 non-fiction books
in text and audio form.
Blinkist has a new feature, Blinkist Connect,
which lets you share your Premium plan for
free with someone else.
Even though it’s shared, both accounts are
separate.
You can get 25% off Blinkist premium and enjoy
two memberships for the price of one.
To try out Blinkist for FREE for seven days,
click the custom link in my description: blinkist.com/newsthink.